if this story were not a tragedy of
ignorance among our elected leaders,
it would be the stuff of comedy legend. But
sadly, it's not because it's so serious. What
am I talking about? Well, Democrats now support
a 15 dollar an hour minimum wage nationally.
Republican Senator from South Dakota John Thune
opposes a 15 dollar minimum wage and he tweeted
that fifteen dollars an hour is just too much. And
his evidence is that back when he was a youngster,
he only earned six dollars per hour tweeting,
quote, I started working by busing tables at the
Star Family Restaurant for a dollar an hour and
slowly moved up to cook the big leagues for a kid
like me to earn six dollars an hour. Businesses in
small towns survive on narrow margins. Mandating
a 15 dollar minimum wage would put many of them
out of business. Now, John Thune is, of course,
either forgetting or ignoring something
called inflation for a moment. Forget about
a productivity adjusted minimum wage. Forget
about a cost of living adjusted minimum wage.
Let's just deal with inflation. John Thune
is 60 years old. He said when I was a kid,
let's say that it was when he was 18 years old,
I my guess is we don't know what year this was,
but we'll say he wasn't 14. He wasn't 16. Let's
assume he was actually already 18 years old when
he was talking about this, when he was working
at the Star Family Restaurant. That would put
it at nineteen seventy nine or more than 40 years
ago, merely adjusting for inflation. Six dollars
per hour in 1979 would be twenty one dollars and
sixty two cents per hour today. And he's opposed
to a fifteen dollar minimum wage based on what he
earned in the late 1970s. Is this some kind of bad
joke? I mean, tell me this is a bad dream
and he's not really this ignorant and maybe
he's not. Maybe he's doing this because he knows
it's his followers that are actually the ignorant
ones. Now, I will be the first to admit I've
conceded before. I've talked about this before.
There are legitimate questions that can be brought
up about a 15 dollar minimum wage in some places,
for example, in a state like Alabama, which has no
state minimum wage, meaning the prevailing minimum
wage, there is the federal one of seven twenty
five an hour. Alabama has a seven twenty five an
hour minimum wage. Cost of living is really
low. It's one of the lowest in the country.
There is a legitimate question to think about if
you more than double the minimum wage in Alabama,
where cost of living is so much lower than
in many other parts of the country, what does
happen to a primarily to a service based business
where labor is the primary input? Now, again,
I'm not talking about McDonald's, where labor
is not the primary input, but rather it's rent
of the of the facility, supplies, the food I'm
talking about, like really a service based small
business in Alabama where they have to double
more than double what every and every employee
is making. We can talk about that. I think
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to discuss.
But Jonathan's argument, I made six dollars an
hour in 1979, so 15 dollars is too much today,
even though six back then is more than twenty
one in today's dollars. That's a non-thinking
argument. He's making a great argument for a large
increase to the minimum wage. He made six dollars
an hour forty years ago. The federal minimum wage
is only seven. Twenty five right now and it's 40
years later. If there is ever a better argument
that the minimum wage is too low, it's that 40
years ago he made six and now it's only seven.
Twenty five. Now, the more likely scenario is that
John Thune does understand this and that ignoring
inflation makes his argument ridiculous. But he's
putting out an argument that his Republican
followers will fall for merely to sow doubt,
which is how these propaganda battles are won
and lost. Get people to hear that talking point
over and over and over again and repeat it, even
if it's obviously ridiculous. Another popular one
for the anti minimum wage people is, listen, if
more money is good, why stop at fifteen dollars an
hour? Make it 50 or 100 or a thousand dollars an
hour, give everybody a thousand dollars an hour,
and then everybody will be rich. And of course,
that ignores that calculating what the minimum
wage should be is not just a calculation of what
would you like to earn? Oh, you want to make
five hundred grand a year. Great. Let's figure
that out. No, you have to have a minimum wage.
That in context is an equilibrium wage adjusted
for inflation, cost of living productivity, etc.
And there is no mathematical argument.
There's no economic argument you could make
for one hundred dollars an hour minimum wage.
I've not heard anyone advocate for that. So
we'll have more about this. My question, which
you can answer, find us on Instagram at David
Pakman show and you can answer there.
Do you think John Thune is this stupid
or do you think he knows about inflation
and just assumes his followers are that
stupid that they'll find fault for this?
Follow us on Instagram at David Pakman,